we need back live waiting for the cosmic
wonder
i i'm live again and i apologize to
everybody for that
weirdness i i had super chat yeah warren
from mr anderson he'll be right back
he's uh fixing it up right now should be
live now my notifications
aren't going to go out for it no there's
no notification he is
he has far exceeded i have exceeded
notification
limitations just on streams alone
yeah okay we're back i'm sorry guys this
is like
all of course all of the freaking crap
what happened
to the finale right i mean of course
that would all happen
but there we go warren's back ladies
[ __ ] let me pull his stream up and put
it here in my bottom corner oh and all
of a sudden people can hear you
right i mean i'm pretty sure watch from
the beginning right
all right let's uh cosmic wonderful
history
yeah i got you here open you up all
right now orange over here y'all can see
now i can hear you hey guys it's me i'm
chris
um i'm gonna wait till more people get
back in here
i have super chats to acknowledge that i
took pictures of luckily
because this is crashed um
way back sorry that was uh
everything all right guys warren's back
if you came over here for more and you
can go back to warren
unless you want to stay then you can
stay
i'm mouthing to the camera come back
come back i'm going to wait till more
people are in
because infinity shades i'm going to do
this a few times because i want to make
sure
i want to make sure they know infinity
shades thank you for that super chat
i'm kind of getting vibes that marvel is
going to download political
route like star wars movies they're
pushing political views in the show
um you know uh kari skoglyn the director
said that
they're not going to shy away from a
political agenda and
i don't know if that's just falcon
winter soldier
um or
that's all going upcoming marvel you
know they didn't have ever on a vision
um and i think they try to kind of be
real and i think
you know because captain america is a
political character he's always been a
political character so i think they're
you know somewhat sticking to the story
from the comics 100
i don't think other stories are going to
be like that i don't think luke's going
to be political because i don't think it
should be and i don't think marvel's
going to do something that they
like shouldn't do but uh
marvel's always kind of been a little
bit political you know
but not un necessarily i think that
there was anything inappropriate about
their message at all
it wasn't political in the sense of like
oh this or that it was just something
that i think the world needs to wrap
their heads around
and it was it was pretty good i think it
was well-mannered yeah
uh matthew king i believe i addressed
that super chat
uh do you think that sharon's gonna sell
secrets norman osborn this is how they
bring him in love
that
i love that i really love that i can't
wait for norman osborn to get mcu man
like that's that's kind of like my like
my jam right now
is like spider man no way home to set up
just so much stuff you know what i mean
like i just i can't wait for that
i like seriously i can't wait for that
we're in an insane building phase right
now and they're building it just
so well yeah
uh i don't think there's any i don't
think there's any
debate that that
the thunderbolts are coming and now i'm
questioning
i'm questioning if sharon is somehow
working for thunderbolt ross
i still think she's connected to him
[Music]
somehow man i was hoping to see
thunderbolt ross at the raft when they
went back to zima
yeah i saw it i was like this is this is
this is this is coming
it's like it's coming hey man
oh no man
i mean there are so many things just in
marvel alone that
you know are open-ended questions like
stark industries
or you know of course all the stuff
going on with spider-man and every
episode every season one division falcon
loki all these are addressing this stuff
and putting us in the right direction so
that's something to be excited about
yeah
yeah um
yeah man i'm kind of sad it's over you
know
um i i'm sad that it wasn't
longer i don't feel shortchanged though
they answered all the questions they
wrapped it up well
do you feel like you needed more i i
guess
yeah yeah like i did like i don't know
they did
they did address all the questions and
i'm not i'm not disappointed
i really enjoyed the finale i thought it
was really good and
i was blown away by sam's suit and i was
really excited to see john walker at the
end
yeah john walker's redemption arc at the
very end i like they fit it into a short
episode but it was very quick and it was
very clear
and it's unfortunate that he's messed up
with with val because she's gonna end up
making it bad again but
yeah so it's really weird because we we
know
we don't know that she's madame hydra
because who knows what the mcu is right
right right
that's not the comics maybe val's
setting up the dark avengers
yeah i was thinking that too yeah trust
in the filmmaker to set up my chat
that's a good point we don't know who
valve's i mean for all we know
val is working for thunderball ross as
well right
right right um
hold on uh isaiah richardson jr thanks
for that super chat
everyone seems to believe that ross runs
the thunderbolts but it's not 100 true
there's also thunderbolts started by
zemo with somber taskmaster fixer
moonstone
and atlas reformed villains yeah and
that was the first team i believe
the first team was zemo's team um
i'd have to look again but um
i think i think they're still
thunderbolt ross's thunderbolts or maybe
that's after yeah i do know the first
team
is zemo led um
i just think with the mcu how uh
ross has been going on and on since the
incredible hulk about the super soldier
serum
make an abomination um
in black widow he's clearly after
something
and i think that's you know the red
viles are different
super soldier serum and i think it's all
going to be
i think i think the red biles might make
him red hulk
uh just because right red right i mean
just because red and red right
right right and that's marvel for you
isn't it
[Laughter]
and that's the interesting thing of that
because after black widow ends which is
obviously way in the past
um whatever serum they have there is
probably gone
right
uh i mean i don't know we don't know
because sharon comes out you know
she's obviously very in the middle of
knowledge and knows everything going on
true and she's like serums off the
market but we got all this other stuff
so serums like almost confirmed
gone right yeah um
oh yeah jay london thanks for that super
chat yeah val's gonna be in black widow
too
so what's she doing in black widow i
don't know but she was
that was when she was supposed to make
her debuts so that's when
thunderbolt ross hires her
yeah right ryan
gliaco hope i pronounced that right
thanks for that super chat
um did i just get another one
yeah it was redacted right uh
well ryan thank you for that i
i don't know your message was but thank
you um
uh episode 6 is already out guys for
those asking we already watched it
um man
a lot of people are kind of saying that
uh
they're kind of disappointed with the
episode i liked it
i i like
john walker's redemption i wanted
i mean they had a lot of bucky
now that i think back to it they did
have a lot of bucky and
i'm disappointed with the yori scene
like
i wanted i wanted there to be more with
him
i
i don't want to say they didn't wrap it
up because i think they did wrap it up
well they wrapped it up as well as they
wrapped up like one division right they
wrapped up the story of what it was
about
well no i'm talking about specifically
the yori scene with bucky and yori
i i wanted
a little bit more detail um
like i wanted i almost wanted him to say
i forgive you like it wasn't you as the
winter soldier
you know i wanted like this big you know
big explanation on what the winter
soldier was if you didn't know
and just say i was brainwashed and you
know this is
it wasn't me it was like me but i was
brainwashed blah blah blah blah you know
i wanted
details and then i wanted jory to say
you know like i forgive you and then he
walks by the window
and just you know but yeah yori has
closure now
and i guess
bucky does too i don't know
uh delay official delay official i'm
sorry if i didn't pronounce that right
do you think steve is on the moon reason
why i ask is people are saying i thought
cap was on the moon
i think that's more like an urban legend
like a rumor that's going around
trying to think but
because sword now is in space right
so that's like the thing right is that
he very well could be on the moon
uh i'm gonna say no i
i think steve's dead
you think steve's dead actually no i
don't know because
no i'm not because we're six months
after end game
steve seemed to be all right uh at
in-game i
i don't think he died in six months he
could be on the moon he could be back in
his own timeline
i i think we get one more steve
appearance
somewhere secret wars i don't know where
but i think we see him at least one more
time i think we see secret wars
yeah they're awesome um that'll that
might have to be like a d
aged uh
a d aged steve which is something they
do a lot right
uh ryan bada gliaco i think yours was
the message redacted before
uh thanks for super chat i don't think
they will do thunderbolts until after
she hoped because they want to establish
abomination again just theory you're
probably right about that
unless thunderbolt ross is the one
who brings bombash back
but yeah you might not be you might not
be wrong i think thunderbolts are
probably
phase 5. i mean i don't see where else
they fit in and what we have left you
know
yeah i mean we know phase four right um
they're not gonna show up at thor love
and thunder they're not gonna show up in
the eternals
right uh i'm not gonna even show up in
loki like it doesn't fit
anywhere maybe armor wars
they could start showing that yeah maybe
our armor wars um
black widow we might get a little bit
more development of it yeah
black widow and and you know marvel
knows the black widow
um marvel knows that black widow was
supposed to be first
and they could have made you know a
little adaptations to
the falcon 9 soldier because of that
point
so maybe there was supposed to be a
little more but there wasn't
i don't know um i think for
phase four i do think it's a rebuilding
phase for marvel
uh-huh i think it's uh not necessarily a
reset
but kind of a reset right starting
basically i think a phase four is phase
one
um right in a weird way um
because something's already established
but um
yeah i thought war machine was going to
show up lol also shout out to
segobob the ozlog thanks for that super
chat
uh that would have made sense wouldn't
it because roadie was there in the
beginning
um channel the grape you think the blip
may have corrupted some people's mind
for example sharon thanks for that super
chat yeah
um you know it wasn't
it wasn't clear on whether or not sharon
was
dusted you know um
in fact in avengers in-game it said she
was dusted
it might not actually you know she might
not have actually it might have been a
scott lang
right it might have been a scott lang
dusted uh
really not dusted just kind of or just
presumed i mean
um
so was she alive this whole entire time
building building her power broker
empire you know
who knows um well you also wonder what
else she's learned you know madrid
is heavily connected with mutants maybe
she knows all this information
and maybe she's learned how
corrupt the government is maybe oh i'm
sure a hundred percent
right um to me it feels like
hydra infiltrating the government again
like hide your infiltrating shield
because they did say their um
you know your old position and then they
call their agent again
but when sharon but when sharon
like she was with shield and then she
was with the fbi i believe or the cia
um so i guess she's back the fbi and the
caa right
i don't think she's you know shield's
not really a thing anymore it's sword i
don't think she's a sword
i think she's going to be you know cia
fbi
and learn some secrets uh
christian henningsen thinks that super
chat
with the episode taking place in new
york where spider-man so this takes
place at the same time as spider-man
far from home does and no way home takes
place right you know immediately after
it so at the same time essentially as
well
so i'm sure they're doing multiverse
stuff
is what i want to say
yeah oh for those people asking uh
who the person in the car was that was
ema's butler
uh i saw some people say professor x was
a professor x
uh yeah walker did redeem himself
welcome
yeah yeah walker redeemed himself um
and i thought that was really cool and
oh man when um
when carly said i didn't mean to kill
him
it didn't matter to me you know i i
didn't mean to kill people that didn't
matter and he gets you you're saying
that
you know lamar's life didn't matter he
got so pissed off and he was kicking her
butt
and i honestly think it's kind of
ridiculous how well she did against him
she's like some chick that's had the
super soldiers here for like a month
he's like a trained army super soldier
with the serum in him now
i feel like he could have made easy work
of her but i guess you needed that for
the show well at one point in time she
kicked him and he just took it he didn't
defend himself
he like kicked him in the chest and he
just kept walking forward yeah
you're a trained army super veteran
special ops
yeah um
yeah i thought that was cool redemption
arc though like i really did i think it
was a good
good full circle for john walker to
become us agent
and now i hope
i hope valentina is not as bad as she is
in the comics
yeah isaiah richardson jr thanks again
for no super chat
i love this more than one division but
one division finale felt more complete
yorio was a missed opportunity
like one division it feels empty as if
the entire series was to make falcon the
new cap
um i think that was what it was doing
um i think you know it's very deep
story very deep story uh falcon give up
the shield
a new person becomes captain america him
deciding what the shield means to him
and then him deciding that he's going to
be the next captain america nobody else
is
uh that was the story right and then
bucky was making his amends and learning
how to
be a person not a soldier even though he
did a lot of fighting right
and he made his amends but yeah no no i
agree yori was a missed opportunity um
i wanted more from that scene that may
be
the one of only two disappointing
things about this finale the other one
being there wasn't
a direct thunderbolt setup
yeah that that would be my other my my
two qualms with it
um yori and no direct thunderbolts
uh sydney danielle thanks for that super
chat
she has something to say for the people
at kabaskin since it was
in new york where spider-man dr strange
was in new york but iron man wasn't
there it's a solo movie hey
there you go preach
yeah a solo series uh about the two of
them which is why
you know when we're talking about cameos
secret cameos
uh captain america showing up uh the old
captain steve captain showing up
um some other people showing up i think
i think marvel is really keeping um
the shows about the characters one
division was about
one division you know and then we had
the villain which was agatha and then
you know white vision
falcon and winter soldier was about
falcon and the winter soldier right and
then we had
villain so um
yeah i think they do a good job with
that uh thomas j flores
most political marvel show slash movie
ever uh yeah i agree with you
but that's typically what captain
america is about
um you know that's pretty politically
charged especially the storyline here
which is the story from the comics you
know in the comics
um nick fury actually suggests
recommends
sam wilson be the new captain america
and they say that you know the world's
not ready for a black captain america
and that's you know that's kind of like
straight from the comics except for
this time it's kind of sam and isaiah
saying that right
i think sam did have the choice
in the beginning because rhodey asked
you know why didn't you take up the
mantle
so who knows um
i'm gonna hop out and start getting the
word warm yeah we're gonna have to uh
all right everybody have a good night
thank you so much warren i'll see you in
a little bit
for work okay bye
uh cam k show starts six months after in
game two months could have easily passed
by finale time putting spider-man in
europe since that takes place eight
months after i thought it took place
six months after am i
wrong on that
i definitely thought spider-man far from
home took place six months after
avengers ending came
in game run time of the show for those
asking
was uh 52 minutes
yes uh
[Music]
the crowd daddy thanks to the super chat
for those of you that watched it that's
pretty funny
well like you died so sad chair marry
sam can you imagine
that's pretty good uh yeah six
is it uh people are saying six months
and eight eight months
months eight months okay
eight months okay didn't assume okay
then we're
i don't know i like uh was
it was sydney who said it i i
mr anderson right that's pretty funny
yeah i i think it's just you know
they're keeping it what it's about
this wasn't about spider-man or doctor
strange or anything like that it was
about you know falconer soldier
uh thank you isaiah richardson jr
appreciate that eight months after end
game okay
so this was before and one division one
division was before
falcon and winter soldier so well guys
i'm really tired and i gotta get my
videos out
um so i'm going to get off now i'm going
to ask that super chat stop because i
don't want to miss any
uh did i get this one yes um
yeah i don't want to miss any super
chats but hey uh for those who didn't
like the finale i'm sorry for those of
you did
i thought it was pretty awesome um and i
think
i think i don't like i don't say this in
like a mean way
but i think the future marvel projects
are going to be better
and i don't mean that as in like i
thought these were bad i'm just so
excited for loki
and yeah i think i think a lot of
i think a lot of crazy stuff is coming
from my i can't wait for doctor strange
multiverse of madness
door love and thunder i mean
there's so much coming there's so much
coming and i'm really excited for it so
all right guys again no super chats i'm
jumping off right now but hey this is
awesome
i'm gonna do some live streams in
between
now and loki uh because they're really
fun and i enjoy talking to everybody
and we're not gonna go
seven weeks without doing this right so
i'll probably do them a few times a week
now there are months
you know one two three times a week
maybe because uh
this is a lot of fun so i'm gonna go do
some videos
and drink some caffeine and maybe get
some sleep eventually but uh
look out for some videos in
[Music]
five and a half hours i'd say
yeah like five and a half hours so hey
thank you everybody thank you to
everybody for
showing up thank you for everybody who
super chatted thank you for everybody
who
just chatted and thank you for everybody
who's just sitting watching and joining
because it's a lot of fun and i couldn't
do this without you guys so
man seven
weeks loki i'm really excited for that
uh
shout out to mr anderson for being an
awesome moderator tonight looks like he
had his hands full
so he did a great job um
and for everybody who had some really
good things to say
really appreciate it love you all and
like i said
five and a half hours video is going to
come out uh i will have a theory
i have them cooking in my head right now
uh it's gonna be engine explained and
then a theory on top of that so
i will see you guys let's do next week
we'll do
a live stream i will announce it ahead
of time uh
i'll do like a community post and i'll
announce on some videos so everybody
knows when it's going to come
so i hope to see everybody back here for
that um and it's going to be fun
so all right guys i will see you
everybody next week and look out for my
video
uh in about five and a half hours love
you all see you next